let's start with the news where OJ
Simpson is back in the news always a
good sign
tangentially because his number 32 which
has not been used by the Buffalo Bills
since he retired from the team is now
back in circulation a player for the
team sonorus Perry is wearing the number
32 Jersey they the team said it was fine
to use it he wanted to use it they
thought it was kind of silly I guess
they thought it was silly that they had
kept this jersey number you know
unofficially retired for OJ Simpson and
now it's back in the field so it wasn't
back in circulation Perry asked for it
Perry joined the team and asked for the
numbers specifically right and I said
sure yeah but I'm sure people I bet
players over the years certainly asked
for it or didn't even know about it to
ask for I'd be shocked but player asked
for it before I'm shocked he asked for
it I'm shocked
first I'm shocked that they did not
retire the number before he killed his
ex-wife and a waiter and also I'm
shocked that they would let this come
back it's insane
they've got 99 numbers and one of them
belongs to a murderer I think it's crazy
that Perry once it and now my question
is like I bet if you went on nfl.com
before this you could not have gotten a
so Jay Simpson Jersey they would not
have let you get a custom OJ Simpson
Jersey my question here how many people
would Senora Sperry have to kill to make
us forget that Oh Jay wore number 32 for
the minutes that you would like you
below Jay Ward that number to like think
about think about how like 4:20 was
Hitler's birthday from a long long time
and then it was the the police code from
marijuana and then it was the
anniversary of Columbine now it's just
like several things that like in 20 min
50 years you forget it's Hitler's
birthday and you just think about Aurora
and your Columbine and you think about
and you think about marijuana but how
many people wouldn't senora's Perry have
to kill I think if he killed anyone
be remembered even more they would just
be remembered as like this is the
greatest you're the most memorable
killing number in NFL history you know
what I mean it would it would almost
raise the stature of the number and
Perry and Simpson what if he killed a
player during the game last Boy Scout
style you know like trying to get into
the endzone pulls out a gun shoots
somebody he's been in the league five
years seems like a good guy doesn't it
doesn't sound like there would be any
indication that they would do it then
why would he want it yeah if he's a good
guy like why would he want this it seems
like a troll move maybe he just wears 32
and so he wanted to have it and he
didn't care about Oh Jay Simpson do you
think that after he scores a touchdown
he points to the ground out of like out
of you know like to say what's up to
Nicole Brown and there's Ranieri
there were there are a few different
takes on this which is which were
surprising though the one that caught my
had the most was Andre Reed who does
have a retired number for the Buffalo
Bills and he said he said I just don't
think regardless of what OJ did off the
field you can just take away what he did
on the field and what he meant to the
NFL I think they should keep that number
retired so he's saying out of respect to
what OJ did on the field that's how
sonorous Perry is being disrespectful
here's what I'm going to say all right
when the Cole Brown Nicole Brown and the
waiter guy got murdered by allegedly by
OJ it was in the front yard where there
is grass grass in the field play ball
technically it's part of the game I
think sooner was Perry I think if he
killed three people while wearing the
jersey with Perry on the back I think he
would eclipse OJ he has to be wearing
the jersey you can't just kill three
people well it wouldn't in the football
accomplishments matter you know for for
young uns like you know Erica you know
Jay Simpson was probably about as famous
a college player as ever and a great NFL
player as well you know in terms of good
husband caring father did
know that Oh Jay was reached for this
story I did not know that Oh Jay is
quoted in this story and he said
whatever they want to do is find that's
how I feel when I played there I tried
to honor the team and since I left I
always tried to honor the bills yeah
that's true he did if you look at the
crime photos he kind of like it's hard
to sit can't he kind of slashed bills
you know I mean like a like a bee ILS
across the waiter which is which is a
tribute I root for I mean Buffalo Bills
are pretty savage beasts they're savage
you know they do some killing
listen Oh Jay Simpson broke the colorway
to honor and Hertz commercials and I
think you should be commended for only
we should forget everything that he did
just because he killed a couple people I
mean Jesus Christ what are we doing here
if you cats why pencils have erasers I'm
getting new jersey I'm getting a
sonorous pair of Jersey and then I'm
gonna kill some people
Jose Simms last week is a man who's
wanted by the Torrington city the city
of Torrington in Connecticut for on for
warrants of first-degree failure to
appear in court three warrants of
second-degree failure to appear his
charges involve drugs DUI all this stuff
there was a wanted poster out there for
him and when the police put that up he
contacted the police on Facebook on
Facebook Messenger and said if you can
get 50 if you can get 20,000 likes and
you put up my wanted poster then I will
turn myself in the cop in charge
negotiated it down to 15,000 likes and
they put it up yeah they've got those
likes they put it up he got 19,000 likes
as of the as of this article still
cranking yeah the gum in 215 the guy was
like okay it went over 15 and the guys
still just chillin which is my favorite
he is toying with the police he's like
the Snowman you know when he leaves
Clues
and he's like come and get me okay give
me some likes I'm gonna I'm gonna come
check myself in and then he doesn't do
it I think it's great I heard the police
played his little game and they got
burned well they even said we don't
expect him to turn himself in but all
the publicity around this could only
help you know possibly get him it
couldn't hurt all these people coming to
where my favorite part of it was they
got it got off to a pretty slow start on
Facebook and he actually left a comment
underneath their posting that said like
oh and this was when it only had 1200
likes and he was he said only thirteen
thousand eight hundred more likes to go
nice job Torrington once it went over
twenty thousand as you mentioned he
never turned himself in and he deleted
his Facebook account it's awesome I
think it's a great I think it's great
whenever people mess with the police and
the police are like mmhmm okay you want
us to post it and get likes for you yeah
we'll do that it's like if you write
like a letter if you've read a letter to
their newspaper and you're like I'm the
Zodiac killer print this they don't do
that anymore
you know if you like tell the police
like you've got to go and do this they
don't negotiate with terrorists this guy
is and now they negotiated with them and
they got burned it's their fault I feel
like there's like I think about
Connecticut that's why it's so small I
feel like there's a think piece to be
done here just about you know the you
know the juice that you can get from a
likes I mean I don't know this it's
there I'm happy that they got all of it
because there's nothing sadder than if
they did it and they just know there was
no response to it whatsoever it's like
there's nothing sadder than like parity
Twitter accounts in general but
especially parity Twitter accounts that
have no followers or those you know
people make a petition like they have a
petition for Game of Thrones to change
the engine all of those are pathetic but
it there especially pathetic when they
can't get many people to do that that's
like the saddest thing in the world I
think the saddest thing is like when
people try that with GoFundMe right oh
my god I like I tore out my knee and I
need money and people were just like
five dollars like no one cares you
should have been like police hello
mister police if you raise $15,000 in
GoFundMe I'll turn myself in
and then it's been like nah I'm cool
[Music]
you